so i noticed last night that ben shapiro
was trending on social media and as i
clicked on his name to find out what he
had done this time i immediately learned
from many left-wing accounts that he had
been apparently
totally owned and demolished and
destroyed in a debate with a college
student during the q a portion of his
speech at unc greensboro this week now i
confess that i was i was
a little biased maybe but i was
skeptical of this claim
for many obvious reasons
then i went and watched the trending
video in question and i discovered that
my skepticism was certainly justified to
put it mildly more than that in fact the
exchange encapsulates nearly everything
that's wrong with the left's approach to
debate in general and debate about
gender ideology in particular
these flaws are only further underscored
by the fact that the left is hailing and
applauding the college student in spite
of the fact that he by any objective
measure and speaking now scientifically
made an absolute ass of himself but
don't take my word for it let's uh let's
go to the tape and watch some of this
i'm a mathematician and a physicist here
a double major and i also just won the
most prestigious award in the country to
pursue research at any institution i
want the national science foundation
graduate research fellowship so i think
i'm pretty you know qualified to say
that most of what you're saying is based
on like old data um but my question to
you
last month right sure um like for
example gender identity disorder that's
the dsm-4 bro we use the dsm-5 now for
psychologists to be able to talk i
literally said the dsm-5 in the speech
and it's called gender dysphoria which
is literally that i use throughout the
speech not generally you sound like a
boso
and you can't even make your wife bro so
what's good
now a couple of things here before we uh
watch the rest of the club first of all
the kid makes a number of false and
confused claims right off the bat but
rather than let ben correct the record
he interrupts calls ben a bozo
because those are the insults that kids
are using these days apparently and
makes an obscene comment about uh ben's
wife now we saw how will smith reacted
to a comment about his own wife and we
saw that smith was largely defended by
the left for reacting that way but chris
rock didn't deserve to be smacked in the
face for making such an incredibly mild
joke
this cut on the other hand
actually does deserve the chris rock
treatment i mean you don't talk about a
man's wife that way i understand why ben
didn't climb down from the stage and up
into the stands and try to commit
assault during the half event of course
but my point is simply that
this is a kid who needs to learn to
watch his mouth i mean something has
gone seriously wrong in society when a
young man feels comfortable
speaking that way to another man about
that man's wife
and one of these days he's going to run
his mouth to someone who is not standing
on stage with cameras all around and
he'll learn his manners the hard way
also
before devolving in almost immediately
into ad hominems
he begins by listing his credentials the
credentials are of course completely
irrelevant to the conversation and will
not make his wrongness magically right
that's not to say that he's lying about
the credentials though the most
concerning and disturbing thing is that
he is not apparently the north state
journal newspaper north carolina they
looked into this and here's what they
found quote one uncg student who got to
ask a question boasted about being a
mathematician and physicist and recently
winning a prestigious national science
foundation graduate research fellowship
award the fellowship which is
nsf says is the oldest graduate
fellowship of its kind spans five years
including three years of an annual
stipend of thirty four thousand dollars
and a cost of education allowance of
twelve thousand dollars paid to the
institution a search of the awardee list
located four
students but only one individual quentin
hosea merit matched the questioner's
description and received an award in
physics and astronomy quantum
information science for 2022. north
state journal reached out to uncg for
comment but did not receive a response
by publication time additionally the
twitter account for the physics
department limited who can see their
tweets after our reporter questioned
them about merit
so apparently the kid with a bad haircut
who thinks yora bozo is an argument and
who accuses a father of three of being a
virgin and who thinks women have penises
and who couldn't even be bothered to
wear a shirt to the event has indeed
received a prestigious academic award
now rather than this fact causing us to
see the stupid kid in a better light it
should cause us to see academia in an
even worse light than we did before
which frankly in my case i didn't think
was possible
now let's return to the clip and see
what else sideshow bob has to say
so
number let me just say
the nice thing about having several
small real questions
if you're using a western colonial idea
of gender then why should it apply if
we're using because because the gender
binary is a western colonial as a
western colonialist framework of gender
you're right men and women don't exist
in any other culture no no no no no no
no no i'm no think about native
americans third gender people i'm not
saying that third gender people are just
native american societies western
african societies like southern native
american societies like mexico so in
other places that are not white
dominated and they like the united
states or europe and so so you're saying
so non-white people i'm a mathematician
and a physicist you cannot tell me so i
have a question and also you're not a
biologist so i have a question
as a mathematician and a physicist what
in the hell do you know about human
biology and you got your law degree from
harvard what do you know about biology
and frankly
and frankly i would ask another question
if your logic is so flawed as a
mathematician and a physicist i would
suggest that whichever institution gave
you an award revoke it immediately
i'm a mathematician and a physicist he
screams while making one erroneous and
incoherent claim after another he says
that the gender binary is a western
colonial idea now even if this were an
accurate claim if it were somehow true
that western colonialists were the first
ones to realize that men and women exist
that wouldn't in and of itself disprove
the gender binary on the contrary in
fact it would just be one more great and
true thing that western colonialists
introduced to the world it'd be another
w for western colonialism i guess
but sadly uh western colonialism cannot
claim credit for that the so-called
gender binary is as old as humanity
itself it is decidedly not true at all
even a little
that non-western countries have an idea
of human sex that falls outside of the
binary in fact
every non-western society on earth
and in the history of the earth
believes that there are only males and
females and i defy you to provide an
actual example of an exception to that
rule
now they may in some cases have some
version of cross-dressing or you know
what we would call gender bending or
whatever but
um they don't believe that men can
actually be women the claim made by this
leftist and by almost every leftist
is the idea that um is that you know the
idea that that men have penises as
uniquely western now if that were true
you should be able to travel outside of
the western world and find hundreds of
cultures that believe
women can have penises
but you don't find that in fact you
don't find any cultures outside the
western world that believe that
i should know
i actually went to africa and
investigated this question
you'll see what i discovered in my
documentary what is a woman when it's
released in may go to what is woman.com
and see the teaser for that for now
suffice it to say that this kid is full
of something and it ain't knowledge i
can tell you that
he mentions native american cultures
this is a reference to the two spirits
quote unquote which is allegedly the
native american version of
transgenderism they put it into the lgbt
alphabet thing now and they put it in
there
so it's lgbt qia
ii
s whatever
the problem is that the term two-spirit
was invented in 1990
by lgbt activists that's how far back
ancient native american history of 1990
is when they came up with this
it is itself a modern western concept
and that's the theme here if you'll
notice
it's an important thing to point out
actually
it is gender ideology
not the gender binary that is modern and
western
gender ideology was invented in the west
by westerners very recently
western liberals have
taken this idea
and tried to spread it throughout the
world
that is the sort of colonization that
happens these days
gender ideology turns out
is not only modern and western but also
in its own way colonialist
the worst kind of colonialism
this is the ideological colonialism
as the left as as you know
liberals in the west
try to ideologically colonize the globe
they may not be planting the flag of a
nation
although
that happens as well but no instead they
plant the gay pride flag
and that's the kind of colonization that
happens
so this kid was
on exactly the opposite side of the
truth
upside down
backwards incoherent
angry stupid confused
and yet
an award-winning academic
it is terrifying to consider how often
all of those things
tend to go to go together
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content